except for the horses really any animal
that has been seen on Game of Thrones
comes from our farm the sheep we go to
the pigs
I was going through difficult times but
Game of Thrones led to a full definite
world for me here I was a wee farmer
from kinda Yamaha it just blew me away
at the start though possible I'm Kenny
Gracie portal farm and was an and on the
farm we have the old traditional breed
animals that are native to the British
Isles namely the longhorn cattle Jacob
sheep and Saddleback pigs I was going
through difficult times and I'm not
ashamed to admit as I was struggling I
was approached by humans and he asked
that I supplied rare and traditional
animals for their production I said yeah
of course and so this was a godsend to
me Joey
angel darling good boy
Game of Thrones afforded me the luxury
so to speak of doing what I love
another's working with animals
comfortable being the animal handler and
taking my animals item set a lot of the
people recognize the affection that I
have for them and the love as far back
as I can remember I've always loved
animals and evolved and delivered my
life that affection that you shoe to an
animal I think they show it back tenfold
[Music]